fais les valises en europe à paris cette
petite phrase qui a beaucoup d'épaisseur
j'ai dit à ma femme françois mitterrand
a décidé d'abandonner le programme
commence à gauche fait les valises on
rentre à paris elle montre bien que
vraiment l'union de la gauche était
largement en europe à paris nous sommes
en 81 un an avant la victoire de
françois mitterrand à l'élection
présidentielle on sait que l'union de la
gauche n'est plus qu'un lointain source
il rappelle en fait un événement qui est
arrivé trois ans plus tôt replantons de
décor depuis 1972 socialistes
communistes et radicaux de gauche sont
unis derrière le programme commun de
gouvernement en 1977 les communistes
veulent qu'un durcissement du programme
mais ils ne s'entendent pas avec les
socialistes notamment au sujet de l'arme
nucléaire française voilà en 77 le
candidat socialiste françois mitterrand
avait dit qu'il ne croyait pas tout à
fait à l'autonomie de cette défense de
la force de frappe française considérant
qu' il n'est pas possible de disposer
d'une force nationale suffisante dans le
cadre d'un conflit universelle capable
d'assurer la sécurité de la france je ne
crois en effet que cas des arrangements
c'est à dire que je ne crois pas à
l'autonomie totale de défense à l'époque
on était en plein été 77 georges
marchais était avec son épouse qui était
également une communiste en corse et
voilà georges marchais raconte j'étais
en corse avec ma femme devant la
télévision et quand j'ai entendu
françois mitterrand c'était à 13h quand
j'ai entendu françois mitterrand refusé
de s'engager sur l'existence d'une
défense nationale
indépendante j'ai dit à ma femme
françois mitterrand a décidé
d'abandonner le programme commun de la
gauche fait les valises on rentre à
paris et qu'en effet il est rentré à
paris en fait il devait de toute façon
rentrer à paris parce qu'elle a une
réunion du parti qui était au début août
77 donc ils l'ont joly eelv un peu la
situation et puis il ya un second aspect
qui bien sûr a fait le succès de je dis
à ma femme fait les valises on entre à
paris
c'est le côté comment dire peu féministe
disons ça comme ça il n'était pas
question lui même de faire les valises
mais c'était les femmes qui faisaient la
valise donc il ya là pour un leader d'un
grand parti de gauche à l'époque le pc
est un grand parti gauche il ya là à
côté un peu désuet une petite phrase qui
prête à sourire dont georges marchais
avait le secret mais qui au fond raconte
la faune du programme commun de l'union
de la gauche qui explosa en septembre
[Musique]